j'ai envie de faire un truc parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un ton aussi
différents c'est en touche pas à mon
poste est-ce que lorsque vous êtes hors
des caméras vous êtes plutôt sympathique
l'un envers l'autre est ce que vous
parler d'autre chose que de politique
parce que même avant de rentrer sur le
plateau vous étiez déjà dans le nom le
débat dans le dans le temps là dans le
temps l'heure dans l'affrontement jordan
je pense qu'il ya un respect il ya un
respect mutuel je pense qu'il ya une
conscience générationnel aussi qui fait
que je parle pas votre place mais
d'avoir sur le dos la responsabilité de
la parole du gouvernement est la mienne
celle de l'opposition fait qu'on a mon
avis très vite grandi et qu'on comprend
un peu
qu'on a peut-être moins le droit à
l'erreur que nos que nos que nos aînés
on est d'accord sur quasiment rien sur
le fond mais ça empêche pas de se
respecter en tant que personne vous avez
déjà ensemble
on se croise conférence à notre
quatrième débat ensemble on se croise
évidemment avant de rentrer sur le sien
sur le plateau etc on n'est pas obligé
de se voir m merci à vous d'être là ce
soir on est maintenant à quelques heures
voilà de l'échéance qu'on attendait
depuis longtemps donc cette élection est
la fin de ce deuxième tour alors est-ce
que emmanuel mc comb être réélu est ce
que marine le pen va être élu pour la
première fois
déjà je voudrais revenir sur la campagne
pour vous c'est vrai qu'il ya eu deux
campagnes différentes marine le pen à la
fais mon pagne sur le long terme
emmanuel macron était le président
sortant donc forcément c'est toujours
plus compliqué parce qu'on sait pas à
quel moment on va annoncer sa
candidature de quelle façon et puis il
ya souvent des gens qui disent dès qu'il
annonce sa candidature c'est qu'il n'est
plus sur les sur les affaires coin parce
que ça continue quand même le travail de
président continue on al'impression
gabriela talent que emmanuel macron il
s'est dit je vais faire
un mois vraiment hot même trois semaines
à font font font vraiment est là et
c'est vrai qu'on l'a vu au monde partout
on le voyait nulle part et l'après il ay
là il a tout fait pour vous est ce que
c'était c'était la bonne stratégie de
campagne voilà et de ce2 ce2 de ce voile
à deux de se présenter à cet art de dire
à cet art qu'il allait être candidat
dira il a même pas fait à la télévision
il a fait dans la dans la presse pour
vous c'est c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
et je pense qu'il ya simplement pas eu
le choix c'est vrai que marine le pen
elle a déclaré sa candidature je crois
pour la première fois il ya deux ans au
moment des municipales elle est pas aux
affaires emmanuel macron il est
président de la république et moi je
suis sûr que s'il avait déclaré sa
candidature plutôt il se serait fait
critiquer on leur a dit quoi vous
déclarez votre candidature en pleine
cinquième vague du coc vide vous n'allez
pas plutôt à vous occuper du covin puis
après on lui aurait dit quoi vous
déclarez votre candidature au moment où
démarre la guerre en ukraine vous devez
pas plutôt vous mobiliser face à la
guerre que mène la russie à l'ukraine
donc il l'a fait au moment où il a pu
c'est à dire oui à cet art parce qu'il
est président sortant est d'ailleurs
tous les présidents sortants qui se sont
représentés l'ont annoncée très tard
parce que ils ont cette charge cette
responsabilité de président de la
république et moi je pense que c'est
wendel est français c'est qu'il soit à
la manoeuvre jusqu'au bout jordan vous
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensez vous de
la campagne
marine a commencé très tôt sa campagne
parce que il y avait beaucoup de sujets
abordés et qu'on partait à cette
élection pour pour la gagner c'est ce
qu'on compte faire dimanche donc on a
commencé effectivement très tôt à faire
beaucoup de réunions publiques à aller
sur le terrain est vraiment une campagne
loin des grandes villes dans les
campagnes aux cartes qu'on a très
longtemps appelée la française oubliez
moi ce qui m'a beaucoup gêné c'est en
fait le refus d' emmanuel macron
quasiment de faire campagne avec comme
la volonté d'enjamber l'élection de
serre qui n'a pas voulu débattre avant
le premier tour pas de débat c'est à
dire que lui jupiter est là haut ils
regardent le peuple s'affronter en bas
puis prendra éventuellement le survivant
il prendra le gagnant pour le second
tour ça ça va beaucoup gêner le coc vide
et l'ukraine ont quand même été c'est
des éléments très importants mais un peu
une excuse parce que le coc vide au mois
de octobre novembre décembre n'y a pas
de vivre ça s'empêche pas de débattre
d'autres sujets et l'ukraine est venue
très très tard dans la campagne
présidentielle donc ukraine ou pas
ukraine en fait on savait qu emmanuel
macron aller attend le dernier moment
pour se déclarer et en fait se déclarer
le plus tard possible
d'abord je trouve que c'est un manque de
respect pour les français pour la
démocratie et surtout pour les autres
candidats qui sont au même niveau qu
emmanuel macron il est peut être
président mais quand il se représente il
est candidat et puis surtout c'est
l'euro en fait ça permet d'éviter de
parler du bilan ça permet d'éviter de
parler de des gilets jaunes la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites du climat de la sécurité du
pouvoir d'achat ça permet en fait mieux
fuir tous les ans par lille avait de
quoi les aider l'armée avant le premier
tour mais jugé en allemagne elle à vous
en parler pourquoi vous n y en a pas
parlé pendant de défaire le débat franc
n'a pas parlé parce que en fait
marine le pen elle a fait un choix qui
était celui de parler d'elle et de son
projet alors oui c'est pas un match de
boxe ça c'est vrai c'est pas un match de
boxe elle n'est pas allée critique
emmanuel macron léger ça les français je
pense le connaissent mais elle avait
vraiment fait ce choix c'est une
stratégie qu'on assume c'était de dire
je veux que dans les 2 heures 40 qui me
sont un parti avec le nombre de sujets
que les français puissent se dire à la
fin du débat voilà ce qu'elle va faire
pour la france et voilà les mesures
qu'elle va mettre en place c'est un
choix alors certes c'est peut-être pas
sensationnel peut-être que vous auriez
aimé un peu plus de combat etc moi je
trouve que c'était un débat extrêmement
clair on voit les deux projets de
société et on peut se dire à la fin du
débat voilà ce que l'un ou l'autre va
faire pour le payer pour les frontières
les meetings pour pour parler je te
demande du fonds du programme et là le
débat permettait justement
vous permettez généralement dans les
meetings vous parlez à vos mini c'est
donc à vous parlez plus du bilan et à la
télé vous avez besoin de gens qui ne
votent pas pour vous donc faut aller les
combrailles ce genre toujours été là
juste il ya eu les autres émissions où
ce qui est des émissions de france 2 il
ya eu face à bakka khel a fait avec
qu'il n'a pas voulu faire oui voilà mais
c'est vrai que il ya eu
il ya eu il ya eu quand même des rendez
vous elle a pu exposer quand même son
son débat là c'est vrai que sur le sur
le débat de l'entre-deux tours on s'est
dit c'est vrai qu'on a eu on n'a pas
posé des questions sur sur les gilets
jaunes bien sûr le sur l'ailé les masses
auriez dû faire le débat alors oui
j'aurais dû 1 1 non mais non mais non
nécessairement pas été imposée par les
candidats si mais en fait je peut-être
dans le cadre par les médecins qui
avaient beaucoup de thèmes et peu de
temps c'est ça va être quand vous allez
10 minutes sur le sahara d'achat vous
n'avez pas le temps qu'on vous dit voilà
on dit mais voilà ce que je vais faire
voilà ce qu emmanuel macron bien faire
et ensuite les français choisissent mais
après le bilan je pense que les français
ressentent les français ressentent
qu'ils arrivent plus aujourd'hui à
boucler leurs factures ils ressentent
qu'il ya une situation d'insécurité qui
est partout dans le pays y voit bien que
les femmes aujourd'hui bah quand elles
sortent elles sont contentes de se
retourner pour voir si elles ne sont pas
suivies parce qu'il ya une insécurité
qui est qui qui touche aujourd'hui
toutes les villes de france que les gens
de plus en plus de mal aujourd'hui dans
certains territoires à trouver un
médecin donc en fait le bilan des
manuels ma quand ils le vivent au
quotidien la politique de mâcon sur les
60 % taxe sur les carburants ils le
vivent au quotidien donc nous on vient
leur dire voilà ce qu'on va faire à la
place voilà ce qu'on va faire
concrètement pour répondre à vos
attentes et c'est la stratégie qu'on a
qu'on utilise pendant le débat gabriella
talent vous non mais le le rassemblement
national il fonctionne beaucoup par des
slogans par des attaques et moi je pense
que si marine le pen a été sur la
réserve de ce point de vue là dans le
débat c'est parce qu'elle savait très
bien qu'elle aurait en face la
contradiction du président de la
république n'aura pu lui répondre ils
nous expliquent à longueur de plateau
dans les meetings que ça a été un
quinquennat de casse sociale la réalité
c'est quoi c'est que le quoi qu'il en
coûte qu'on a fait pendant le coït c'est
la plus grande politique sociale qu'on a
connu ces dix vingt trente cinquante
dernières années nous explique en
permanence qu'on abandonne les services
publics le secteur de la santé 30
milliards pour l'hôpital public car on
n'a jamais vu ça dans l'histoire de
notre pays il explique on voilà tout ce
qui se passe dans le pays ce serait de
la faute des manuels macron les 60% de
taxes il ya une légère augmentation en
2017 qui avait été annoncé pendant la
campagne les légères pour les gens
depuis il n'y a pas eu d'augmentation
totalité gelés on a même fait des
mesures qui sont plus efficaces que
celles qui proposent pour faire baisser
la facture des français donc la réalité
c'est que marine le pen elle est bien
obligé de reconnaître je crois que
c'était un des enseignements de ce débat
que le bilan il a permis des avancées
très concrètes pour les français on a le
taux de chômage le plus bas depuis 15
ans taux de chômage des jeunes le plus
bas depuis 40 ans le taux d'emploi de le
plus haut depuis qu'il est mesuré qu'on
a eu des profs des progrès aussi sur le
réchauffement la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique sur le pouvoir
d'achat alors et donc non je dis pas que
tout a été parfait et gabriel dis juste
que c'est facile quand on est dans un
meeting ou sur un plateau télé de
balancer tout et n'importe quoi à toutes
les attaques possibles mais à un moment
quand on est dans un débat face au
président de la république ça devient
plus difficile d'argumenter gabriela
talent aussi on a l'impression que le
que le président il a attendu la fin du
premier tour pour se dire ça y est
maintenant je suis écolo à fond c'est
vrai ou pas du tout non on est écolo
depuis maintenant pas en parler pas du
tout avant le premier tour et là entre
les deux tours gérer un plat c'était
dans son programme avant le premier set
j'avais l'impression yannick jadot
non mais d'abord et on a fait beaucoup
ces cinq dernières années sur
l'environnement la france est le premier
pays au monde qui a interdit la
recherche et l'exploitation
d'hydrocarbures sur son sol on a financé
dix mille kilomètres de pistes cyclables
on a fait une loi qui interdit le
plastique à usage unique on va plus vite
que tous nos voisins européens mais on a
rénové 700 mille l'an dernier logement
de français non mais je dis juste ce qui
a été fait et je vais y ait ensuite mais
on sait aller bosser on sait que au seco
lors du premier tour il a eu une petite
carence sur les plus jeunes et on se dit
il à y être abordés des sujets
l'écologie ça parle aux mobiles les
voilà donc j'allais
mais c'est important pour moi de dire ce
qu'on était un tueur on a bien c'est les
émissions de co2 en france de 12% sur le
quinquennat qui vient de s'écouler c'est
deux fois plus que dans le quinquennat
d'avant où pourtant les écolos était au
gouvernement donc ça c'est ce qui a été
fait ensuite évidemment quand vous avez
un premier tour que vous avez une partie
des jeunes notamment qui envoie un
message en votant pour un candidat parce
qu'il considère qu'il est plus investis
que les autres sur la question de
l'environnement c'est normal de dire que
vous entendez ce message ça me semble
même plutôt sain démocratiquement de
dire voilà il ya eu un premier tour il
ya des résultats qui placent à ces eaux
certains candidats qui amy la question
de l'environnement la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
très en avant et ben j'en tiens compte
effectivement il va falloir qu'on fasse
plus plus fort et plus vite sur ces
questions-là trouve ça plutôt sain et je
trouve ça sain d'entendre le message des
électeurs et notamment des jeunes le
problème c'est que les français ne
ressentent pas comme ça sert que le
président a tout fait pour fuir les
débats et il arrive au second tour en
expliquant que tout va bien on a fait en
a fait sauf que les français ne
ressentent pas comme ça et une grande
partie des crises qu'on a eu pendant le
quinquennat c'est emmanuel macron qui
les a déclenchés il faut se rappeler que
le mouvement des gilet jaune
c'est lui qui le déclenche d'abord parce
qu'il augmente et vous l'avez rappelé à
demi mots quand il arrive à la tête de
l'état les taxes sur les carburants
c'est à dire qu' il ya des millions
d'afghans serre dans les produits en
kilomètres heure il ya les 94 des
minerais quatre ans est aujourd'hui
n'arrive plus à en faire le plein de
leur voiture qui sont obligés de limiter
les déplacements alors qu'ils ont besoin
de leur voiture je veux dire yahia il ya
qu'anne hidalgo qui pensent qu'on peut
se déplacer en continu de partout sur
les pistes cyclables mais il ya des gens
dans les campagnes ils ont besoin de
leur voiture pour aller travailler pour
aller chercher les entrailles des
galeries il ne leur reste plus qu'à
d'ailleurs plus grand chose à y aller
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que quand vous dites oui il ya une
augmentation c'est léger mais pour les
gens c'est important pour les gens c'est
conséquent et nous quand on vient leur
dire si on arrive au pouvoir on va
baisser on va faire de l'énergie un
produit de première nécessité c'est à
dire qu'on va baisser la tva de 20% à 5
5% sur les carburants l'essence et
l'électricité le gaz le fioul et sur un
plein par exemple des sens on va le
rendre 15 à 30 euros de pouvoir d'achat
mais vous pouvez dire c'est léger mais
pour les gens c'est beaucoup pour les
gens c'est considérable donc moi j'ai le
sentiment que le président est
complètement déconnecté qu'il est
complètement déconnecté de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans le pays de ce
qu'attendent les français et c'est pas
pour rien si marine est arrivé en tête
dans vingt-deux mille communes dans deux
tiers des communes en france on a mis
marine le pen en tête et c'est notamment
dans des communes rurales dans toute
cette france qui oublié les politiques
publiques et moi ce qui m'a beaucoup
choqué pendant le débat c'est l'attitude
d' emmanuel macron complètement avachi
au fond de son fauteuil
non mais on s'en fout pas je suis désolé
on est président de la république en se
tenir correctement c'est respecter le
candidat qui est en face et c'est
surtout respecter les millions de
français qui d'abord vous regarde là on
s'en fout pas toi je suis désolé moi ça
me choque moi ça me choque parce que se
comporter comme ça ça veut dire qu'on
respecte pas la personne mais pour qu'on
ait encore pourquoi mais j'irais pas
jusqu'a la cuisine exquise mai mais
pourquoi lui reste pas là et surtout les
gens croient pas qu'ils n'arrivent pas
les wii en direct
elle n'est pas maîtresse d'école mais
vous n'allez pas là elle aurait dû la
tolère sans nous mais quand ça se
présente devant lui elle se présente pas
comme opposante qui importe est une
critique elle vient dire je suis une
femme du nord je vais très dans leur pic
et voilà ce que je vais faire pour les
convaincre et je vais même vous dire
salariat la tête europe agressive vous
auriez tous dit ah ben c'est comme en
2007 elle est agressive lui qui avait un
bilan très malin c'est lui qui l'a
interrogé sur son programme ck oui
je méritais et vous le savez je prends
jamais partie des points sur sur
l'économie je suis désolé moi j'ai de ce
que j'ai vu j'ai vu quand même que le
président ils connaissaient quand même
bien ses dossiers elle éclate et c'est
bien ses dossiers vous trouvez pas
jordan franchement non mais connaissait
bien ses dossiers je suis désolé on vote
pop non mais on est plus fin les deux
sont pas candidats au grand oral de
l'ena oui mais il maîtrise le chiffrage
show léon sens important je veux dire
longue à emmanuel macron il a fait six
ans le mozart de la finance 1 600
milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire 600 milliards d'euros
donnait alors le ministre
ouais non le ministère des comptes
publics ça vient pas l'exil ont dit
qu'ils osent et 250 millions et 150
millions dans 250
l'elysée le ministère des comptes
publics par tour de contrôle de ce
campus et vos chiffres 250 milliards sur
les six en hiver c'est sahara peter
locaux vides le reste c'est de la
mauvaise gestion alors disent oui c'est
la sécurité sont d'accord mais c'est le
budget de l'état donc
j'adore sauf que aujourd'hui eh bien les
français ressentent pas ça les français
ils ont du mal aujourd'hui à payer les
factures ils ont du mal aujourd'hui à
remplir le plein de la voiture et ils
n'y arrivent plus donc on a fait du
pouvoir d'achat un thème important de la
campagne et on prend nos gains notamment
c'est cet engagement qui est de rendre
150 à 200 euros de pouvoir d'achat par
mois aux français ça c'était ça a été le
début du débat ça va juste genre
j'ordonne mardi j'aimerais que gabriella
tad vous répondre sur l'attitude qui a
été énormément reprise des manuels
maternelle et fonde sur tout ce qui a
été dit sur moi je regarde toujours le
parti de ne pas interrompre mes
adversaires dans les débats et donc
jordan bardella par les adjoints temps
et donc je vais pouvoir attraper exhale
à l'arrêt le temps la galerie surtout
corriger beaucoup de bêtises et de
mensonges qui ont été formulées d'abord
sur la question de l'essence c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu un mouvement d gilet jaune
ce mouvement des jeunes johnny venait de
loin il venait de probablement plusieurs
années ou plusieurs décennies d'abandon
de service public dans beaucoup de
territoires et oui le sentiment pour
beaucoup de français alors qu'ils
bossent de pas réussir à boucler les
fins de mois il a été effectivement
déclenchée c'est le couvercle qui a
explosé à ce moment là par une taxe
carbone qui devait augmenter on a annulé
cette hausse qui avait déclenché le
mouvement des gilets jaunes ça c'est sur
le premier point ensuite vous avez parlé
des prix du carburant et vous avez
rappelé la proposition qui est celle de
marine le pen de baisser la tva pour
répondre aux coûts du carburant nous on
est en désaccord absolue avec cette
proposition pourquoi parce que on a vu
par le passé en france ce qui se passait
quand on baisser massivement la tva on a
un exemple la tva a été abaissée
massivement pour les restaurateurs
c'était en 2009 est ce que les français
ont vu sur leur facture quand ils vont
au restaurant une baisse des prix pour
eux banon peuvent y aller et donc la
réalité la réalité jordan bardella c'est
qu'avec votre proposition c'est les
marges des distributeurs de carburant
qui augmenterait les français y verrait
pas la différence les professionnels les
artisans les commerçants les chauffeurs
de taxi qui travaillent qui se font
rembourser la tva il verrait pas la
différence pour eux puisqu'ils se la
font rembourser donc nous on est passé
par un autre système qui effectivement
la ristourne à la pompe parce que ça au
moins vous en bénéficier c'est pas le
distributeur qui se la met dans la poche
et donc il ya cette baisse de 18
centimes au litre est complété par
beaucoup de distributeurs 10 centimes en
plus pour total tout ça ça fait bien
plus que rendre la petite augmentation
qui avait eu en 2017 sur l'essence si
c'est vrai les chiffres sont là c'est
pour la première chose sur la question
de la dette c'est vrai que c'est un
argument qui a été utilisé par marine le
pen pendant le débat et manuellement le
répondu d'accord mais l'essentiel c'est
de quoi qu'il en coûte qu'est ce que
vous auriez fait différemment sur quoi
qu'il en coûte vous auriez - aider les
entreprises du reste vous auriez - aider
les restaurateurs vous auriez mans aider
tous les salariés qui ont pu garder leur
boulot grâce au chômage partiel
incapable de répondre on n'a pas entendu
sa réponse on l'attend toujours donc la
réalité encore une fois c'est que c'est
facile de faire des critiques c'est
facile de dire que tout est mal que tout
ce qui est fait est mal que tous les
problèmes des français sont de la
responsabilité du président de la
république mais quand on rentre dans le
détail quand on vous demande qu'est ce
que vous auriez fait différemment qui
vous auriez - aider vous êtes incapable
de répondre et les propositions vous
faites sur la tva elles font que si
votre programme était appliqué les
français ils perdraient du pouvoir
d'achat notamment sur l'électricité
aussi la facture d'électricité elle
s'envole partout dans le monde parce
qu'il ya une demande très forte et qu'on
sait qu'il ya des tensions avec la
guerre en ukraine si on n'avait rien
fait au mois de février dernier la
facture moyenne des français auraient dû
augmenter entre 300 et 400 euros pour
tous ceux qui nous regardent on a fait
le blocage des prix de l'électricité ce
qui fait que la facture moyenne a
augmenté de 40 euros parce qu'on a
bloqué les prix si on n'avait pas fait
le blocage des prix mais qui avait eu la
baisse de la tva la facture elle a
augmenté de 150 à 200 euros tout ça
c'est c'est c'est juste du calcul de
base parce que la réalité c'est que
c'est plus efficace que de bloquer les
prix pour être sûr qu'ils augmentent pas
plutôt que de baisser la tva ce qui vous
garantit pas que les prix vont continuer
à augmenter alors un match on voulait ya
perte soit on a appris pendant le débat
mais avant moi ce qui me choque c'est
que un programme ça s'explique et ça ne
se lit pas et pardon mais emmanuel
macron n'a fait aucune campagne
politique chez de coeur avec alain
duhamel qui a dit c'est la pire campagne
de la vème république il a fait un cas
un meeting il a refusé tous les débats
il a refusé toutes les missions et tous
les cas sa ba ba il a tout refusé on a
même le sentiment avant vos données qui
ne voulait pas y aller on sait que les
pressions sur le toit de choix que de
chaque élection on s'en foutait complet
et précis c'est inouï
avant aucune idée aux gens ça oui
vraiment ça m'a choqué comment on peut
faire une campagne aussi faible il s'est
caché derrière l'ukraine c'est
formidable ukraine mais pardon nous ont
vus en france alors on est très content
de ces deux traits on est très très
touché par ce qui se passe au nucléaire
et pertes mais nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est les cinq années qui vont
venir en france et s'est caché derrière
ça et je trouve qu'il a fait une
campagne qui était vraiment très très
méprisant alors gabriel on peut vous
répondre je veux pas revenir sur le
sujet du timing moi je sais je suis sûr
que s'il avait déclaré sa candidature
plutôt on lui aurait reproché en lui
disant qui s'occupait pas des dossiers
qui préoccupent les français c'est sur
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il s'est déplacé beaucoup sur
le terrain qu'il a été à fouras qui l'a
été à pau qui l'a été à poissy qui l'a
été il avait clamé le déplacement quand
il raconte la guerre ici pour discuter
avec des mets attendait déjà des matchs
mais il a fait aucune émission aucun
débat si hier il a fait des émissions il
a changé que des auditeurs il a fait
brut on lui a mis des noms des délais
compte 104 ces prêts dont il avait il
avait gagné
la raison ils étaient très contents de
le voir dans ces tabous et bien sûr
j'adore il a très bien fait ça
dès qu'il allait bien se passer
c'est à vous voilà c'est pas paris siwel
les honnêtes ou non là vraiment entendu
marine le refuge les micros deux
quotidiens
attendez il a fait des émissions avec
des auditeurs qui ont interpellé il a
fait brut avec des jeunes qui
l'interpellait via les réseaux sociaux
il est sur le terrain il se fait
interpeller par des gens y compris
parfois il se fait bousculer oui donc
arretez de dire c'est dans l'événement
alors vous n'êtes pas content parce
qu'il n'est pas venu à face à bah je
l'entends pas qu' aucun compte aucun
candidat ne peut faire voir que les
émotions de toutes façons vous faire des
choix pouvait pas tout faire il lui
encore moins puisque par ailleurs en
plus d'être candidat il est président de
la république donc juste il à des
sommets internationaux il a des conseils
des ministres a présidée marine le pen
n'a pas fait toutes les émissions non
plus il ya des choix à faire le mal à
dérouler la banque de données mois il et
la présidente
désaccord les jours jordan on a encore
un président et les français qu'ils
attendent on est encore un président
pour prendre des mesures pour les
protéger et pour continuer à présider la
république jordan bardella mais il a été
il a été à arras il a été il était dans
le nord a donné un parent dont il a été
à saint denis mais a surtout il a
surtout été hué en vérité il a fait peu
de déplacements peu de campagnes parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'il sort il est hué
par les français qui n'en peuvent plus
de sa politique maintenant pour parler
de la campagne d'entre deux tours il n'y
a pas seulement face à bah ça il faut
savoir que nous avons été sollicités par
votre chaîne pour faire face à bah on a
accepté immédiatement et sans aucune
condition comme la dernière fois on a
été sollicité par france télévisions
pour faire une grande émission politique
s'appelle élise et 2022 et on a été
sollicité par exemple encore récemment
par le parisien pour faire une interview
faut savoir que le parisien comme c'est
de la presse écrite n'est pas soumise
aux mêmes égalité temps de parole donc
le parisien peut faire juste un
entretien de marine le pen si magnola
qu'on ne souhaite pas la faire il n'y a
pas de règle d'égalité qui s'applique et
manuela coin refusé de faire le pas le
parisien le parisien a annulé
l'interview de maïwenn qui devait sortir
hier ses huit emmanuel macron n'a pas
voulu la faire on a dû annuler notre
participation à l'émission elise et 2022
on devait faire cette émission on a dû
l'annuler parce que emmanuel macron n'a
pas souhaité venir donc en vérité il a
tout fait pour confisquer le débat et
moi ça me pose un problème parce que à
la base la france est une démocratie et
la france avec emmanuel macron ça
ressemble de moins en moins à une
démocratie ça quand on n'est pas
d'accord avec vous soit n'y a pas de
débat soit scellé l bd soit c'est les
insultes le mépris la violence et ne pas
vouloir débattre ne pas vouloir se
confronter c'est un manque de respect
pour les français et je me demande si
emmanuel macron il aime les français
parce que quand on se comporte comme ça
on vient dans une élection on rend des
comptes au peuple français et d'anglais
magnola quand il n'a pas voulu d'une
élection il voulait être nommé ces deux
nominations par tacite reconduction et
ce principe là ils me posent un problème
et il dit beaucoup de la conception
qu'elle magnola contre la démocratie et
surtout de ce que vont être les cinq
prochaines années s'il devait être réélu
donc profiter de la liberté d'expression
autant que vous l'avez en corse pas
garanti que vous l'ayez encore pendant
les cinq ans il devait être réélu par
accident on croyait même pas à ce que
vous racontez et franchement parler et
donner des leçons démocratie quand on a
pour alliés pour référence au niveau
mondial marine le pen elle a été
interrogée c'était il ya quelques mois
elle a dit mais deux références dans le
même c'est rump et c'est poutine mais
deux modèles part pas en vacances à
brégançon je vous ai pas mais on a des
mers voulait pas interdit mais deux
modèles mais deux modèles dans la vie
c'est trump et poutine ont pas du tout
rump il a fini en demandant à ses
partisans d'aller en valeur le parlement
le capitole poutine il en train de
bombarder un pays parce que c'est une
démocratie dont vous avez pas de leçon à
donner sur la démocratie c'est la
première chose ensuite oui le président
a participé aux plus d'émissions
possible qu'il pouvait il a participé
d'ailleurs à une émission sur tf1 avec
tous les candidats on n'avait jamais vu
un président lars noren et les sciences
attendait participer à une issue aussi
rêver la mission qui était la messe tous
les autres candidats non pas du tout
vous êtes là à parler de n'importe quoi
la réalité c'est que vous voulez pas
qu'on parle du fond du coeur mais
c'était quoi c'est quoi l'histoire sur
l'émission de tf1 pareil tf1 il devait y
avoir un débat avec tous les candidats
emmanuel macron n'a pas souhaité
débattre et donc l'émission s'est faite
avec des entretiens à la suite d un
détour et du tout ce qu'ils n'ont aucun
parti ça pose un problème et toutes les
chaînes ont fait autant de mensonges que
vous voulez toutes les chaînes ont voulu
organiser des débats et les débats n'ont
pas pu faire parce qu emmanuel macron
les a refusées donc je trouve que c'est
vraiment un manque de respect pour les
français mais on peut parler du fond et
des mesures liées aux captures non mais
là on parle en bon là on est vraiment
dos sur un faux rythme on est sur la
campagne bat karé ment on est sûr les
mesures et on les a vus encore
je dis non juste après on peut
comprendre aussi ce que dit gabriela
talent est ce que vous dites khawaja
tally dit c'est vrai qu'il a dû faire
des choix à un moment c'est vrai qu'il a
fait énormément de l'arbre en quinze
jours il a fait nommer l'un juste
j'entendais jordan bardel à dire il a
été hué et c'est depuis 1er tour qu'est
ce qu'on a vu on a vu deux sortes de
campagne on a vu emmanuel macron qui a
effectivement fait le choix pour ces
déplacements d'aller dans les villes où
il a fait ses moins bons scores et ou
plutôt le front national jean luc
mélenchon ont fait leur meilleur score
il aurait dû aller dans une émission il
a fait les moins bons ce qu'on attendait
et marine le pen elle a fait le choix
d'aller dans les villes où elle faisait
ses meilleurs scores avec un quart de
militants qui étaient là pour
l'applaudir c'est une campagne en
chaussons mais dans des halls d'hôtels
dans cette note
emmanuel maintenant ils allaient se
confronter oui c'est aussi difficile sur
les marchés pendant que vous êtes à
paris bien déconner garder mon visuel a
été regardé les déplacements qu'elle a
fait ces dernières semaines elle a pas
pris de risque emmanuel macron c'est sa
marque de fabrique il va face à des gens
qui sont pas d'accord avec lui oui pour
essayer la maintenance qui l'a fait plus
gros à quoi vous ne vous est pas qu
emmanuel macron n'a pas voulu faire face
à va pas parce qu'il ne voulait pas être
ni face à ses contradictions façade et
gilet jaune face à des gens qui étaient
mécontents du traitement de la crise au
vide parce que l'argument pardon mais
l'argument de je n'ai pas le temps de
faire toutes les émissions quand on voit
qui fait brut qui fait booska-p sait
très bien qu'un site spécialisé dans le
rap pardon mais là je suis plein temps
j'adore mon nom mais bien sûr c'est
super il peut faire face à bague fait 2
millions de téléspectateurs là il fait
des médias confidentielles ou et où il
est bien traité on va le brosser dans le
sens du poil donc l'argument de je n'ai
pas le temps et crs il avait déjà confié
jag libéré défendez
ça permet des habitants ancienne sherpa
si vous avez regardé dans le bayou
bernard devant brut c'est l'interview
abrite je peux vous dire qu'il a été mis
aux amis face à des questions qui
étaient traduits laissé à beaucoup moins
d'un black que face à marat passé sur
dimanche au malawi mais du coup pourquoi
il n'a pas fait face à va pas parce
qu'on vous a pas pu menacer par gabriela
talent ne faisait pas bon ce n'est pas
discuté avec lui des mamans vous devez
faire des choix quand maintenant où les
candidats doivent faire des choix aucun
ne peut faire toutes les émissions et en
plus lui et président de la république
il va non des sommets internationaux il
préside le conseil d'état et moi je peux
vous dire d ouvrir je peux vous dire mon
sentiment alors mon sentiment je pense
sincèrement qu'il n'avait pas besoin de
faire face à bas et que c'est ici je
fais sa façade à marine le pen va faire
face à doivent apprendre et que est-ce
que lever et fils d'haïti important et
je voulais je vous dis j'aurais fait
pareil franchement je les ai déjà dit si
j'aurais fait pareil je vois les
sondages il dit franchement sur 27 28
qu'est ce que je vais faire je vais pas
le faire il n'a pas fait face à baba et
ça c'est ma conviction a peut-être fait
d'accord mais parce que marine le pen
aurait fait ça aurait été très bien
comme la dernière fois et je vous dire
quand elle a fait face à bah ya eu un
avant et un après et il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont vu dans cette émission est
d'ailleurs je joue en match parce que je
pense que c'était une des meilleures
émissions politiques de l'âme de la
campagne je pense qu'elle n'a rien à
envier aux émissions plus traditionnel
mais qui permet de se confronter d'abord
de pas d'aborder la politique simplement
et surtout de confronter le candidat à
la présidentielle à des français à des
gens à des infirmiers à des policiers à
des gens qui viennent d'horizons divers
à des opposants politiques là où c'est
vrai que c'est bien marine le pen a été
très bonne et elle était vraiment ce
qu'elle a fait une campagne de terrain
parce qu'un seul combat sur le quotidien
des français parce qu'elle a parlé de la
santé qu'elle a parlé aux infirmiers
qu'à la paille des déserts médicaux
qu'elle a parlé de la sécurité mais on
faire des propositions et pascal
nouvelle version nettement en accord sur
les appellations et des barres peut pas
dire qu'elle ne fait pas attention il ya
un sondage qui disait que 50% des
français je crois trouvé que marie le
pen faisait la meilleure campagne et
d'ailleurs même ici je pense que si on
met union ni si vous votez pas
massivement pour marine le pen mais quoi
qu après on sait pas mais vous avez tout
dit à plusieurs reprises qu'elle faisait
une mélodie pas parce que vous allez
vous faire sortir de l'antenne
en vérité si marine le pen a été
qualifié au sera semblable c'est parce
que les français ont vu que elle parlait
de l parler de leur quotidien qu'est
leur apportait des réponses et surtout
qu'elle pouvait battre emmanuel macron
le maintien voit plus les compteurs là
c'est l'inversé gabriel qui est
producteur mercedi
savoir combien moi je le dis parce qu'il
ya plein de gens je dis moi je leur ai
dit les choses il ya plein de gens sur
les risques en tiens mon compteur qui te
je ne suis pas d'accord avec mon
compteur
mais je ne suis pas gai brillant natale
à ses jours il ya plein de gens qui
m'ont je me la joue au jeu raconte-t-il
m'envoyer des sms qui vaut sur les
réseaux je vois des gens qui me laisse
des mots qui me disent oui pourquoi est
ce que tu es fâché après après le
président après le après la république
en marche qui ne sont pas venus enfin ça
va alors je vous dire moi je ne suis
fâché après personnes chacun fait ce
qu'il veut moi quand je n'ai pas envie
d'aller dans une émission où quand je ne
sens pas un truc ou quand je me dis j'ai
pas le besoin d'y aller franchement j'y
vais pas et c'est pas pour ça que je
vais me fâcher avec avec les personnes
chacun fait ce qu'il veut et j'ai
vraiment aucune amertume et je suis très
content voilà qu'il est soit les dents
c'est ta bouche très content pour eux
quoi qu'ils aient fait magali berda qui
les faits bruts c'est vraiment voilà je
pense qu'il ya de la place mois pour
tout le monde voilà je le dis il ya de
la place pour tout le monde dans cette
campagne avait de la place pour tout le
monde donc j'ai vraiment aucun problème
s'il ya plein de gens qui me voilà qui
essaient de me chauffer sur les réseaux
pour que pour que voilà que pour la pour
que je m'énerve un peu et je vais vous
dire franchement chacun fait ce qu'il
veut et quand les gens ne sont pas
obligés de venir voilà marine le pen a
bien voulu venir jean luc mélenchon
voilà mais valérie pécresse eric zemmour
ils sont venus ils ont voulu venir et
puis voilà ils ont fait voilà jean luc
mélenchon c'est un moment peut-être
aussi où ils avaient besoin aussi de
face à bâle moi aussi j'avais besoin de
lui voilà donc c'est vrai que eric
zemmour c'est le premier qui est venu il
c'est vrai que c'était un moment on
parle énormément
c'est mon celi pour nous c'est une
opportunité parce que parle énormément
lui donc c'est vrai qu'on a vu un bon
timing avec chaque candidat et on aurait
aimé avoir le président de la république
emmanuel macron avec nous dans face à
bale maintenant il n'est pas venu puis
face à bah ne s'arrête pas on sait
jamais voilà peut-être que on refera 1
face à baba plus tard puisque c'est ça
va ça va continuer vous n'avez jamais
vous avez un petit peu de retard gabriel
donc si vous avez des avis non non j'ai
rien à dire
valentino et sinon sur dimanche moi j'ai
une dernière question à vous poser tous
les deux assez la fin ouaip à bientôt
non on a parlé on a parlé quasiment que
de dénommer on parce que j'ai eu des
deux fonds non mais parce que le fond je
vous lis le fou il on vous en avait
parlé et il est le président et marine
le pen en appareils ils en ont parlé
jeudi mercredi longuement justement vous
si vous aviez un tube un truc à dire aux
français aujourd'hui sur le projet
emmanuel macron et vous jordan la dallas
sur le projet de marine le pen qu'est ce
que vous leur diriez face à la caméra
comme ont pu faire les deux candidats
mercredi soir voilà si vous aviez vous
deviez résumer le projet projet d'
emmanuel macron et vous le projet de
marine le pen je dirais que c'est un
projet qui agit pour l'indépendance de
notre pays à l'indépendance des français
parce qu'on veut pas être soumis à
l'étranger on veut pas dépendre de
l'étranger pour se chauffer pour se
déplacer pour travailler pour s'informer
pour se défendre et que ça ça passe par
une europe plus forte ça passe par des
investissements massifs pour le travail
des français on a un bilan là-dessus
taux de chômage le plus bas depuis 15
ans pour le pouvoir d'achat on a fait
des choses il faut continuer il faut
aller plus loin et aussi pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique et je
dirai ensuite aux français parce qu'il y
en a certains qui nous regardent qui
hésitent peut-être aller voter dimanche
qui hésitent à s'abstenir qui avait
peut-être voter pour un autre candidat
je leur dirai que dimanche à 20 heures
qu'ils aillent voter ou non il ya un
visage qui apparaîtra sur les écrans et
que ça peut être le visage de l'extrême
droite et que c'est pas la même chose de
voter pour un candidat qui est fidèle à
nos valeurs celles de la république qui
est fidèle à je pense des objectifs que
partagent une grande majorité de
français est une candidate qui veut s'en
éloigner et que la réalité c'est que si
marine le pen était élue présidente de
la république pas la france sortira de
l'union européenne et c'est nos jeunes
qui veulent faire en erasmus qui
pourrait plus le faire c'est tous les
gens qui travaillent dans des secteurs
qui sont très liés au tourisme qui sont
liées aux exportations qui se
retrouveraient à pénaliser si marine le
pen est élu il aura rien pour
l'environnement elle veut d enlever les
éoliennes qui sont en france c'est à
dire qu'on va rouvrir des centrales à
charbon c'est à dire qu'on va rapporter
plus de pétrole plus de gaz si marine le
pen est élue c'est pas les valeurs de la
république qui seront défendus parce que
sa priorité s'est demandé aux policiers
d'aller course et les femmes qui portent
le voile oui on leur retirer leur voile
pour les verbaliser ses normes a tissé
dans ces produits parce que sa priorité
c'est de dire à des enfants à des jeunes
qui sont nés en france qui vont devoir
être expulsés de leur logement social
parce qu'elles sont pas français le
soleil ne se lèvera plus
soudée mais ça va être horrible vous
réagissez comme ça
chez moi je vous ai pas interrompue mais
dans le programme de marine le pen ya
une mesure qui s'appelle la priorité
nationale page 9 dans son livret famille
elle dit on va pouvoir libérer six cent
vingt mille logements sociaux dans
lesquels il ya des familles étrangères
en les expulsant pour les redonner à des
familles françaises évidemment si c'est
écrit c'est écrit page 9 dans l'ivresse
à sortir des gens bah oui mesdames à
libérer rapidement c'est la joie dans
lesquelles il ya des familles étrangères
des étrangers qui sont là en situation
régulière qui travaillent qui ont des
enfants qui sont nés en france voulait
les sortir de leur logement c'est ça
votre programme c'est pas les valeurs de
la république et nous on défend les
valeurs de la république jordan bardella
mais je pense que je pense qu'il ne leur
reste que là que la peur la caricature
est une forme d'anathème aussi parce que
d'aller dire que marine le pen est
extrémiste ça veut dire qu'en fait on
insulte des millions de français qui
s'apprête à voir en vrai ce que j'ai dis
donc je pense
non mais dès que je veux dire au lieu
d'expliquer que le soleil ne se lavera
plus si nous sommes des luges parce que
j'ai dit non plus j'ai donné et
répondait sur le français vous
connaissent bien maintenant marine le
pen ça fait 20 ans qu'elle est qu elle
les défend et je pense que même les gens
qui sont en désaccord avec elles peuvent
lui accorder 7 700 séries t évidemment
qui a rien de tout cela que si elle a
lieu sera la présidente de tous les
fenêtres à la priorité nationale et je
vais vous dire je vous répondrai moi je
veux dire aux français qui nous écoutent
d'abord d'aller voter parce que s'ils ne
vont pas la politique dimanche c'est la
politique qui va venir à eux pour les
cinq prochaines années et je veux juste
leur dire soyez libres n'écoutez pas les
marchands de peur qui tentent de se
sauver de sauver leur poste en vous
faisant peur en essayant d'effrayer les
français ça fait des années que vous
subissez les mêmes politiques des années
que pendant les entre-deux tours on
essaie de vous faire peur de vous
manipuler dimanche dans l'isoloir il est
vrai jean bardet l'assuré ligue 2 c'est
libre de votre choix au vu des
projections officielles je vais vous
dire moi dit il va nous faire je verrai
rendez sur les propos je vais vous dire
moi je suis inquiet la réélection des
manuels macron dimanche si ça devait se
produire parce que je sais que ça va
être 50 saccage social parce que vous
voulez faire travailler les français
jusqu'à 65 ans des millions de français
qui nous pompe à travailler jusqu'à 65
ans parce que sur les impôts sur la
fiscalité sur les taxes sur les
carburants sur la baisse des appels pour
les jeunes que vous avez fait mal et on
continue à les fils il m'a supprimé la
blague d'habitation rue calme importe je
pense que le véritable extrémisme tel
qu'il a été conduit depuis cinq ans
était manuel macron donc je veux dire
aux français tout ça c'est pas une
fatalité on peut faire différemment de
tout ce qui vous est imposée depuis
depuis 30 ans dans notre pays on peut
vous redonner du pouvoir d'achat on peut
baisser les impôts on peut exonérer les
jeunes l'impôt sur le revenu on peut
doubler les aides aux familles
monoparentales et aux mères de famille
qui sont de plus en plus seuls et isolés
qui sont parfois obligés de cumuler
plusieurs jobs donc n'écoute et ce avec
de l'argent magique ip sur les marges
non rigolade mais juste avec des choix
politiques donc à l'argent pour financer
pour finir je lui ai proposé dans les
détails avant le film secondes comme ça
vous allez me répondre sur la priorité
nationale et le voile et oui justin
défend jean caricature non mais ils sont
sur sa i la maison
expulser les gens je vous réponde sur
l'or mais c'est vrai que sur ce point là
c'est important comme alors deschamps la
priorité nationale c'est là qu'on veut
que dans les nous jouons va pas expulser
les gens des logements étaient racontées
marqué libérer rapidement des logements
620 mille logements dans lesquels il ya
des familles étrangères je vais vous
répondre c'est nos soignants j'ai laisé
des soignants étrangers des caissières
et travaillent et qui ont un logement
social mais vous ont des enfants nés en
vous a trait à bien s'en passer c'est
très calme et je vais notre écart vous
est excité vous êtes fébrile vous étiez
des trucs délirants je suis moi je vais
vous dire je ne suis pas énervé sur
cette proposition oui je vois bien mais
je vais vous et david région profonde
mais bon ça vous êtes énervé à tort je
vais vous expliquer ce qu'on souhaite
faire c'est que on souhaite instaurer
dans l'inconscient la priorité nationale
cirque on souhaite que dans l'accès à
l'emploi ou dans l'accès au logement à
compétences et à situation égale les
citoyens français citoyens sans aucune
distinction est une priorité d'accès
c'est à dire qu'on se demande que dans
les nouveaux logements sociaux les
citoyens français est une priorité
d'accès dans les dossiers qui sont
choisis par rapport aux gens qui
viennent de l'étranger pourquoi parce
que le logement le hm c'est une aide
sociale et que ce sont les français qui
cotisent à cette aide sociale et il ya
beaucoup de familles françaises
les familles pauvres qui vivent dans les
campagnes qui vivent dans la creuse qui
vivent dans le cantal qui n'ont pas
accès aux mêmes aides qu'ailleurs et qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir bénéficier d'un
logement le temps de pouvoir aller mieux
le temps de pouvoir gagner plus donc on
dit juste cela et c'est une aide qui
vise c'est vrai à dire aux français vous
n'avez qu'une maison dont vous serez y
aurait largement dans le pays des 620
milles dont vous dites que vous allez
libéré rapidement parce qu'il ya des
étrangers dedans je rappelle que les
étrangers c'est des soignants des aides
soignantes des infirmières qui sont
étrangères qui travaillent c'est des
caissières c'est des gens qui
travaillent pour les françaises avaient
bottines malmené les un chemin mais
juste ils sont où les 620 mille hommes
et qu'on va expulser remarquer que vous
aller libérer rapidement s'ils
s'enfuient logement parce qu'il ya des
familles donc ses 620 mille logements
salomé gens qui nous regardent je le
regarde et on va vous dire vous ferez
croire à personne pense qu'il n'y a pas
un français dans la rue qui pensent que
marine le pen est extrémiste locale et
d'extrême droite enfin sur les plateaux
télé ça dit tout sauf dans la rue ça dit
tout serait ensuite jusqu'au money
répondre sur le financement du logement
social comment est-ce qu'il est financé
le logement social qui finance la
construction de logements sociaux il est
financé par les français qui doivent
aller financer parti il est un
dispositif qui s'appelle hajib logement
oui innoncent action logement il est
financé par les loyers qui sont payés
par les gens qui sont dans les logements
sociaux donc les étrangers qui sont dans
un logement social ils payent un loyer
ce loyer est bien dans sa construction
je l'assumé et donc arrêter de les jeux
là sur les étrangers sont des petits
bénéfices n'est peut-être pas d'un
cotiser sans payer c'est pas vrai on est
petit on est d'accord là dessus mais la
priorité nationale l existant dans la
fonction publique il faut avoir la carte
d'identité française pour se présenter
au concours ça existe quand dans la
nation dans les élections par exemple il
faut avoir la carte d'identité française
pour se présenter aux bureaux bureaux de
vote ça existe aussi et bien on souhaite
que dans le logement pardon je l'assumé
les familles françaises sans aucune
autre distinction est une priorité
d'accès au logement par dont vous jouez
à suivre je repars que vous vous trompez
pas il le dit tous les invités et 620
milles rapidement et deux personnes
malades et saint-gabriel at-elle
quatrième ce qu'il en sera et après sur
la fait que vous allez demander à nos
policiers qui ont quand même mieux à
faire pour la sécurité des français
c'est pour ça qu'on a recréé 10000
postes qu'on les paye mieux on l'a
renouvelé leur voiture qu'on règle les
commissariats ils ont mieux à faire pour
les français c'est à dire aller trinquer
traquer la délinquance les voyous dealer
de drogue qui est plutôt que plutôt que
comme le propose le rassemblement
national à les traquer les femmes
voilées pour leur demander de retirer
leur voile ou les verbalisée parce
qu'elle porte le voile saison là aussi
vos propositions est ce que vous mettrez
en oeuvre marine le pen était s'appelle
pas rassembler les français ça s'appelle
les diviser en raison de leur religion
c'est exactement l'inversé de nos
valeurs et je crois des valeurs d'une
grande majorité des français qui
voudront éviter ce genre de projet
terrible en allant voter dimanche est
donc
vraiment vous qui avait enfermé 40
français pendant les pauses il va
racheter sur été contrôlés demandé à la
police républicaine à les contrôler les
attestations sur internet et vous en
étudiant on pourra les vrais de malley
la loi cette maladie ni slam pour vous
il y avait une maladie une maladie et
donc oui on a contrôlé pendant un temps
mais vous allez lire pendant un temps
restreint et que les gens portaient leur
masque vous ce que vous dites c'est que
il faut dorénavant que la france
devienne le seul pays au monde qui
interdit le voile dans l'espace public
et que nous puissions travailler
monsieur adam la rue oui dans l'école
parce qu'on forme des consoles et donc
là c'est encore si elles veulent décider
ou pas de le porter et donc dans la rue
on serait le seul pays au monde où les
policiers quand il ya une femme voilée
ira les voir en leur disant je vous mets
une amende vous retirer votre voile
immédiatement et je vous mets une amende
c'est ça la priorité pour nous voler je
vous rappelle que le pays merci en
disant que c'est contraire à la civilité
française mais enfin michel blanc car
qui dit qu'il n'est pas souhaitable
d'endosser donc on pourrait en parler
des heures pas juste fuyez les
caricatures et à les lire ce passage
merci gabriela talent merci
lors d'un mariage